[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visual politik zuschauer stellt
euch vor es ist krieg und keiner geht
hin auch nicht die bundeswehr weil sie
nicht kann weil die geschütze nicht
schießen die flieger nicht fliegen und
weil die truppe nicht trainiert er ist
für den kampf gegen den feind was ich
soeben so überspitzt formuliert habe
entspricht zurzeit dem ruf der
bundeswehr in der öffentlichen debatte
in deutschland die fähigkeiten und
abwehrbereitschaft der bundeswehr gelten
als so schlecht dass man sich fragt ist
deutschland auch einen krieg vorbereitet
konnten wir einen feindlichen angriff
wirklich werden selbst ranghohe generäle
verneinen dass und zwar öffentlich schau
her die bundeswehr das her das ich
führen darf steht mehr oder weniger
blank da alfons mais generalleutnant und
inspekteur des heeres der bundeswehr am
tag des russischen überfalls auf die
ukraine auf linkedin das ist starker
tobak insbesondere angesichts dessen was
deutschland lädt er kostet die
bundeswehr ist bei der höhe der
militärausgaben nummer zwei in der
europäischen union über 47 milliarden
euro gab man 2021 für die armee aus das
ist das gleichauf mit frankreich dem
spitzenreiter in der eu damit fällt fast
ein viertel aller eu ausgaben auf die
deutsche streitkräfte über zu wenig geld
dürfte man also nicht klagen oder nicht
meine einerseits ein üppiges budget und
andererseits eine wehklagen de
generalität irgendwas passt doch hier
nicht zusammen wie steht es wirklich um
die fähigkeiten der deutschen truppe so
verschwindet das ganze geld könnte sich
deutschland überhaupt noch verteidigen
wenn der krieg nach mitteleuropa kommt
ganz ganz viele von euch haben uns diese
wichtigen und spannenden fragen gestellt
und schon lange habt ihr uns darum
gebeten ein video nur über den zustand
und die perspektiven der bundeswehr zum
drehen nun ja jetzt ist es soweit heute
machen wir den großen aufwasch zugegeben
eine abrechnung aber wie immer eine
konstruktive und faire abrechnung dieses
video wird lang es wird breit und es
wird tief wir werden alle relevanten
details der deutschen abwehrbereitschaft
schonungslos beleuchten und aus auch in
das große damit zusammenhängende über
die militärische dimensionen ausgehende
historisch gesellschaftliche gesamtbild
einführen am ende dieses video ist
werdet ihr genau verstehen wo die
probleme der bundeswehr liegen und wo
die lösungsansätze also holt euch eine
ordentliche portion popcorn und etwas
kühles zu trinken schnallt euch an und
dann geht es los wie immer beginnen wir
mit einem schnellen blick in die
geschichte
ein kind des kalten krieges
1955 wurde die bundeswehr gegründet das
war zehn jahre nach dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs warum aber erst so spät in
einem sechs jahre nach gründung der
bundesrepublik nun nach dem horror der
deutsche soldaten im zweiten weltkrieg
verbreitet hatten war die
demilitarisierung der deutschen die
oberste devise deshalb verboten ihnen
die alliierten siegermächte aufbau
eigener streitkräfte auch als sich die
zwei deutschen staaten ddr und die
bundesrepublik 1949 bildeten hatten
diese noch keine eigene armee
doch einige details hatten sich schon
geändert das misstrauen zwischen ost und
west nahm rapide zu der kalte krieg
gegangen
da bildeten sich zum beispiel in der ddr
bereits 1948 auf geheiß des vds erste
polizeieinheiten die in kasernen
untergebracht waren dies war die
sogenannte kvp die kasernierte
volkspolizei sie gilt heute als
vorläufer der nationalen volksarmee nva
der armee der ddr doch auch im westen
wuchs die bereitschaft zu kompromissen
in sachen militär angesichts der block
konfrontation mit dem vorwerk
schließlich war ein koreaner 1950 aus
dem kalten bereits ein heißer krieg
geworden die staatschefs der
westalliierten förderten im 150 eine
wiederbewaffnung der westdeutschen und
im falle eines angriffs durch die
sowjets westeuropa zu verteidigen und so
entstanden auch im westen zunächst
kleinere paramilitärische einheiten wie
etwa der bundesgrenzschutz bgs der weg
zur regulären streitkräften weiß geredet
und wie ein wettrüsten schritt auch
schon die wiederbewaffnung voran 1955
entstand im westen die bundeswehr und im
gleichen jahr war man bereits mitglied
der nato und innerhalb der nato übernahm
die bundeswehr eine verdammt wichtige
rolle im falle einer sowjetischen
invasion war hauptsächlich den deutschen
die rolle des stolperdraht zugedacht das
hieß die gewaltigen panzer armeen des
warschauer pakts aufzuhalten die den
westen zahlenmäßig überlegen waren wir
werden nie wissen ob sie das im
ernstfall geschafft hätte aber auf jeden
fall wurde die bundeswehr für diese
aufgabe üppig ausgestattet ab etwa den
siebziger jahren bieten in ihrer rund
500.000 soldaten plus reserve machte das
1 3 millionen mann für den kriegsfall
materiell kann man in den 1980 er jahren
auf zwölf die visionen des heeres die
über mehr als 7000 kampf und
schützenpanzer verfügten 15 fliegende
kampfverbände der luftwaffe und marine
besaßen insgesamt rund 1000
kampfflugzeuge die marine verfügte über
40 raketen schnellboote 24 u boote und
einige wenige zerstörer und fregatten
die bundesrepublik deutschland stellte
somit seit ende der siebziger jahre die
zweitgrößten streitkräfte in westeuropa
wohlgemerkt nach dem amerikanischen
verbänden dabei gehörten einige
waffensysteme der bundeswehr auch noch
zu den modernsten ihrer zeit etwa der
leopard kampfpanzer oder tornado
kampfbomber doch der kalte krieg war
1990 zu ende gegangen und ab da ging es
bergab mit der schlag auf der bundeswehr
schaut er
[Applaus]
zwischen ende der 80er und mitte der
90er jahre verlor die bundeswehr rund
150.000 soldaten
sie wurden durch den wegfall der
sowjetischen bedrohung einfach nicht
mehr gebraucht die personalstärke der
bundeswehr reduzierte sich von den
spitzenwerten im kalten krieg bis zum
heutigen zeitpunkt um mehr als 60% logos
setzt eine armee heftig zu vor allem
einer solchen die so konsequent auf die
abwehr des gegners ausgerichtet war der
aber nun wächst ihm als tresor politics
zuschauer wisst ihr aber sicher
personalstärke ist nicht alles beim
militär es ist eher ein kennzeichen
moderner armeen dass diese dank neuer
technik weniger truppen brauchen das
problem ist aber dass diese
technologischen möglichkeiten viele
ressourcen erfordern eine starke
wirtschaftliche basis innovation und gut
ausgebildete soldaten die high tech
waffen effektiv einsetzen können daher
lautet die frage hat die bundeswehr den
wandel zu einer kleineren aber modernen
armee erfolgreich vollzogen oder es
zumindest versucht und was genau ist
seit dem ende des kalten krieges schief
gelaufen sodass der eingangs erwähnte
general zu solch einem vernichtenden
urteil über seine eigene truppe kommt
lasst uns das alles mal etwas genauer
unter die lupe nehmen
[Applaus]
militär lass mal die anderen machen
[Musik]
deutschland ist die bei weitem führende
wirtschaftsmacht in europa und gemessen
am bruttoinlandsprodukt die viertgrößte
der welt gleich hinter den usa china und
japan doch trotz seiner wirtschaftlichen
stärke zu sein lädt er gibt deutschland
nicht viel mehr als ein prozent seines
bruttoinlandsprodukts aus nach der
russischen alexion der krim 2014 stiegen
die ausgaben zwar sie liegen aber immer
noch unter den zwei prozent des bip
welche sich die nato staaten zum ziel
gesetzt haben leider bildet hier
deutschland keine ausnahme die wenigsten
mitglieder der allianz erfüllen die zwei
prozent vorgabe zudem ist fraglich wird
das geld überhaupt effizient eingesetzt
und hier besteht ein gewaltiges problem
trotz der ausgaben von 150 milliarden
euro besteht ein großteil davon aus
irrsinnig hohen personalkosten und
überbordender bürokratie und diese
schwerfällige bürokratie mitsamt
endloser vertrags prozesse führt zu
einem gewaltigen modernisierungsstau
seht her
die bundeswehr droht zu implodieren wenn
der verteidigungsetat nicht massiv
erhöht wird um die maroden waffensysteme
zu modernisieren droht ein abbau und der
armee andré wüstner vorsitzender des
bundeswehrverbandes in der kölnischen
rundschau am besten sieben 2020 von
bürokratie monster bundeswehr war damals
die rede neue waffen flieger oder
schiffe wurden gebraucht aber nicht
angeschafft bestehendes
materialverschleiß wurde aber nicht
erneuert und schon gar nicht
modernisiert das ganze geld floss in
einen fetten banken apparat in
ineffiziente strukturen die aber nicht
kämpfen können wenn bis zum krieg kommt
mit anderen worten das problem in
deutschland ist nicht nur dass ein
geringerer teil des bip das militär
ausgegeben wird alles versprochen das
geld wird auch noch äußerst schlecht
eingesetzt
[Musik]
die deutschen haben aus ihren
milliardenschweren
verteidigungshaushalt einen
selbstbedienungsladen für politiker
deren freunde und verwandte alle arten
von bizarren interessenvertretern und
einen unglaublichen wasserkopf gemacht
dessen zweck hauptsächlich die
maximierung seiner selbst ist kaum
jedoch der ursprüngliche die optimierung
der verteidigungsfähigkeit des landes ja
man muss es klar sagen auch dies ist
eine form der korruption
die systemische zersetzung einer
staatlichen strukturen die ihre
handlungsfähigkeit verliert weil zu
viele ihrer ressourcen zur befähigung
von zwei fremden partikularinteressen
abgezweigt werden provisionen und
pensionen statt panzer und proviant
heißt hier die devise aber scherz
beiseite die bundeswehr ist weit davon
entfernt eine moderne und schlagkräftige
armee zu sein obwohl sie jedes jahr so
viel geld verschlingt ich meine das muss
man sich auf der zunge zergehen lassen
50 milliarden euro und besonders traurig
wird dies im vergleich mit anderen denn
das ist mehr geld als südkorea jedes
jahr für die verteidigung ausgibt ist
was doppelt so viel wie australien seine
truppen gibt und mehr als das doppelte
des israelischen
klar deutschland mag größer sein als
israel oder auch südkorea aber bei
operativ militärischen fähigkeiten sind
diese länder viel besser und vor allem
sind sie ja einer permanenten bedrohung
durch direkte und aggressive nachbarn
ausgesetzt sie sind also gezwungen eine
viel höhere abschreckung bevölkerung
durch ihr militär zu finanzieren das
problem deutschlands wird deutlich wenn
man sich die folgende tabelle ansieht
nur 18 prozent der deutschen
militärausgaben werden für militärische
ausrüstung ausgegeben auch das liegt
unter dem nato mindestwert von 20
prozent und multipliziert mit der
unterschreitung der gesamt budget
vorgaben um die hälfte ein prozent statt
2 prozent ergibt sich bei der ausrüstung
somit ein defizit von sage und schreibe
55 prozent gegenüber dem nato minimum
das schlimme daran diese krasse
schieflage war bei großen teilen der
deutschen wählerschaft lange zeit
hochgradig populär diese
selbstverstümmelung wurde gar zu einem
politisch gesellschaftlichen fetisch
neue waffen militär verteidigung für
deutsche war das in den jahrzehnten vor
dem ukraine kriegt ein unpopuläres oder
besser nicht vorhandenes thema politiker
waren bei waffen käufen stets
zurückhaltend und verwiesen oft auf die
schrecken des deutschen militarismus und
die katastrophe der nazizeit und ja auf
den ersten blick mag derartige
zurückhaltung als ein verständlicher
teil der nie wieder philosophie
erscheinen
ja natürlich da von deutschem boden nie
wieder ein angriffs- und
vernichtungskrieg ausgeht diese
moralische prämisse jedoch als billige
ausrede dazu missbrauchen sich aus einer
eigenen geschichtlichen wie
kontemporären verantwortung zu stehlen
und auch die verteidigung seiner
schwäche an demokratischen nachbar und
seine bündnispartner und nicht zuletzt
sein des eigenen landes zu pfeifen ist
schon pervers ich nutze ganz bewusst
diese starke vokabel denn die pathologie
dieses denkmuster das fußt auf gleich
mehreren bewussten die unbewussten
elementen zum einen handelt es sich
wieder um eine zutiefst germano
zentrische sicht und das ausgerechnet
bei jenen die jegliche form von
nationalismus strikt von sich weisen
denn das böse kann eben nicht nur von
deutschland ausgehen im grunde muss man
damit rechnen dass es jederzeit überall
entstehen und sich genau dann ausbreiten
kann wenn es nicht rechtzeitig gestoppt
wird daher ist es logischerweise vor
allem wichtig dass alle demokratische
staaten in erster linie natürlich die
großen mächtigen und wegen ihrer
verantwortung zur verteidigung von
freiheit und demokratie nachkommen und
zwar proportional zu ihrer größe und
macht fähigkeiten und verantwortung
müssten in einem gesunden verhältnis
zueinander stehen denn hätte sich
präsident roosevelt im zweiten weltkrieg
so verhalten wie heute die deutsche
regierung hätten die achsenmächte die
weltherrschaft ganz klar nach und nach
an sich reißen können ohne die massiven
waffenlieferungen der usa wäre die
sowjetunion wohlgefallen schließlich auf
die usa gegen einen konsolidierten
eurasischen kontinent keine chancen
gehabt hätten schließlich war es doch
eine zentrale lehre aus hitlers krieg
und den fatalen folgen der politik das
ist ein letzter instanz eben das
allerwichtigste ist sich und seine
freunde verteidigen zu können und dann
auch rechtzeitig zur verteidigung bevor
es zu spät ist eine große historische
lektion die viele deutsche politiker und
meinungsmacher einfach nicht kapiert
haben oder nicht kapieren wollen denn in
vielen fällen geht es natürlich um gut
funktionierende geschäftsmodelle und
auch im reinen populismus gegenüber
großen teilen der wählerschaft es ist
lange her seit man einen wahlkampf in
deutschland mit der forderung nach mehr
verteidigungsausgaben gewinnen konnte
und auch wenn dies viel aktion teil
durch übertrieben und falsch
verstandenen pazifismus oder historisch
bedingt ist begeisterung ja das
misstrauen der deutschen in ihre eigene
demokratiefähigkeit selbst bedingt war
die große dominante war schlicht und
einfach ein allgemeines desinteresse
über alle bevölkerungsschichten hinweg
[Musik]
laut einer umfrage aus dem jahr 2017
hielten und 9 prozent der deutschen eine
erhöhung der verteidigungsausgaben
wichtig 91 prozent der befragten hielten
sie für irrelevant unzureichend oder
hatten gar keine meinung denn verhandeln
statt schießen diplomatie statt militär
das war die bundesrepublikanische
tradition doch diese haltung so
sympathisch wie auch sein mag hat ihre
tücken wie man im falle russlands jetzt
sieht
sie hat nichts gebracht nur einen langen
tisch lange gesichter und einen langen
krieg schließlich wurde auch die
sowjetunion nicht durch die romantische
ost west ernährungspolitik der regierung
brandt und schmidt in die enge getrieben
und zu fall gebracht sondern durch das
knallharten wettrüsten ronald reagans
und während deutsche politiker den
militarismus der vergangenheit
abschwören aus gut war schwangen dabei
viele zum anderen extrem über und
kritisiert nur allzu gerne den
angeblichen militarismus der usa und der
nato aber genau von amerika und der nato
ist deutschland extrem abhängig findest
die eigene sicherheit geht deutschland
ist nach japan das land mit der
zweithöchsten zahl an us
militäreinrichtungen auf der welt über
20 liter was ein amerikaner findet man
in good old germany mindestens 35.000 us
soldaten sind noch immer in deutschland
stationiert das sind mehr als zum
beispiel in südkorea einem land das ich
richtig gesehen immer noch im krieg mit
nordkorea befindet also kurz gesagt
fehlende ausrüstung lebende bürokratie
und sicherheitspolitische abhängigkeit
von den usa die bundeswehr ist in einem
beklagenswerten zustand oder auf gut
deutsch wenn es hierzulande knallt muss
anders sein seine kanonen stecken sonst
ist deutschland verloren ihr denkt wir
übertragen nun seht euch mal folgendes
sagen
egal wo man hinschaut es gibt
funktionsstörungen hochrangiger
deutscher offizier im hauptquartier der
bundeswehr
aber wieso hat dies in deutschland
niemanden interessiert nun wie bei so
vielen wichtigen zukunftsthemen die hier
weil wir so günstig übrigens regelmäßig
angesprochen wurden haben die nippel
regierungen hand in hand mit einer
abgerichteten medienlandschaft aus
gebühren finanzierten
hofberichterstattern und karriere geilen
schoßhündchen journalisten die republik
in einen kollektiven dornröschenschlaf
geschickt und das böse erwachen kam am
24 februar dieses jahres als russland
die ukraine überfiel mal wieder musste
der deutsche mainstream auf die harte
tour erkennen wie weit daneben man mit
seiner einschätzung der situation und
seine urteilsfähigkeit lag und endlich
erkannten auch deutsche politiker in
welcher traumwelt man die letzten
jahrzehnte in deutschland lebte die
bittere erkenntnis auf sich allein
gestellt würde die bundeswehr keinen
krieg führen können und das sagen nicht
nur wir unter chef des heeres schaut
euch mal das jahr
der auf fröhliche deutsche umgeben von
freunden mit steigendem lebensstandard
nicht besorgt um die sicherheit wenn es
ein problem gibt kümmern sich die
amerikaner darum das gehört der
vergangenheit an ekkehard große
präsident der bundesakademie für
sicherheitspolitik
die deutschen haben sich in falscher
sicherheit wiegen lassen in dem glauben
dass es nie wieder einen krieg in europa
geben würde das ergebnis ist dass wir
über zwei generationen hinweg vergessen
haben wie wir uns verteidigen können
armin berger vorstandschef des
rüstungskonzerns rheinmetall gut nach
den bösen erwachen erfolgten zumindest
erste taten deutschland endlich
ordentlich geld in die hand die meisten
erinnern sich sicher darauf
historische wende von kanzler scholz 100
milliarden zusätzlich für die bundeswehr
scholz wir werden ein sondervermögen
bundeswehreinrichtungen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten ende juli
wurde dieses sondervermögen auch
hochoffiziell vom bundesrat beschlossen
da haken daran das sondervermögen ist
gar kein sondervermögen denn es soll
einfach dafür verwandt werden das
sowieso fällige 2 prozent minimal ziel
der nato zu erfüllen und das obwohl es
ursprünglich hieß dass diese mittel der
truppe wirklich zusätzlich das und
bereitstehen sollten tja das ist so als
wenn dir dein arbeitgeber erst über
jahre hinweg die hälfte des vertraglich
vereinbarten als zurückhält und dir die
verspätete nachzahlung dann als
lohnerhöhung und super duper bonus
verkauft so was ist eine bananenrepublik
würde ich aber nicht der stärksten
wirtschaftsnationen europas
ach ja und was mit dem zwei prozent ziel
passiert wenn die 100 milliarden
aufgebraucht sind nun da gibt es wieder
nur ganz vage unscharfe versprechen sich
bloß nicht festlegen man wolle dann
schon die zwei prozent aber wie man dies
angesichts der wirklich irregulären
ausgabenstruktur aus dem sondervermögen
sind voller effektiv gestalten wolle
dafür hat die bundesregierung keinerlei
nachhaltigen plan nun denn vielleicht
wäre dies angesichts des
kompetenzprofils dieses kabinett
wirklich zu viel verlangt denn schon die
sinnvolle und fallen effiziente
verwendung der jetzt zur verfügung
gestellten mittel stellt aufgrund der
tiefen strukturellen verwahrlosung eine
mammutaufgabe da wieder gleich sehen
werden hat das jahrelange
vernachlässigen der armee tiefe spuren
hinterlassen die sich nicht einfach so
beseitigen lassen indem man einen haufen
dummen geldes drauf ruft haltet euch es
gut fest denn wir zeigen euch was da
wirklich los ist
[Musik]
eine truppe in trümmern
im kalten krieg war sie eine geachtete
und vielleicht auch gefürchtete
streitmacht heute könnte der gegensatz
kaum größer sein von charly nicht fahren
und schießen flugzeuge die nicht fliegen
und u-boote die nicht auslaufen das ist
die realität der bundeswehr 30 jahre
nach ende des kalten kriegs und es sind
keine geheimnisse von denen wir sprechen
jeder politiker und jeder bürger kann in
den jahresberichten des wehrbeauftragten
des bundestages nachlesen wie es um die
truppe bestellt ist jedes jahr im
frühjahr wird das veröffentlicht und in
den medien darüber berichtet zb der
jahresbericht 2009 10 darin heißt es die
bundeswehr als ganzes ist folgte noch
nicht ausgerichtet und aufgestellt für
eine kollektive verteidigung der
damalige wehrbeauftragte dr hans peter
bartels fasst die lage der armee in
einem zeitungsinterview einmal so
zusammen es
fehlt überall umher in der luftwaffe in
der marine dr hans peter bakker ist der
beauftragte des bundestages im
tagesspiegel am 27 07 2010
und die mängelliste betrifft sogar dinge
die jeder soldat am leibe trägt da fehlt
es an kugelsicheren westen an stiefeln
oder nachtsichtgeräten zum teil
besorgten sich die soldaten ihre
ausrüstung privat und auch den
verbündeten bleiben solche zustände
nicht verborgen bei einem besuch von us
beamten in litauen stellten diese mit
entsetzen fest die bundeswehrsoldaten
kommunizierten mit unsicheren
mobiltelefon weil sie nicht genügend
verschlüsselte militär von geräte haben
es gab keinen einzigen deutschen
soldaten der mit dem dort verwendeten
funksystem vertraut war oder im umgang
damit unterwiesen worden war wenn es um
die ausrüstung gegenüber internationalen
übungen zur verfügung steht ist die
bundeswehr regelmäßig das schwächste
glied in der kette bericht des deutschen
bundestag ganz genau es handelt sich
hier um die gleiche fatale
sicherheitslücke die den russen den
schnellen vormarsch auf die vermasselte
die absolute möglichkeit des feindes zur
spionage oder sogar manipulation szabo
tage der aufklärungs und kommando
kommunikation im ernstfall wäre die
bundeswehr also allein schon deswegen
die achillesferse der nato nicht nur
bedingt abwehrbereit sondern ein echtes
sicherheitsrisiko mit dem potenzial die
schlagkraft des ganzen bündnisses zu
untergraben und das ist noch nicht alles
von der gesamten militärischen
ausrüstung der bundeswehr ist nur ein
kleiner teil 1 ist bereit dann zu
schweigen davon dass viele der
vorhandenen geräte in betrieb und
einsatz die an sie gestellten
erwartungen und anforderungen gar nicht
erfüllen können der wasserkopf der dafür
verantwortlichen beschaffungs bürokratie
ist nämlich nicht nur hochgradig
ineffizient sondern auch ebenso
ineffektiv das heißt er selbst
verursacht nicht nur exorbitante durch
nichts gerechtfertigte kosten sondern
ist auch nicht in der lage mit den ihm
zur verfügung stehenden mittel und
prozessen ein beschaffungs technisches
system zur sicherstellung der
funktionstüchtigkeit der
militärausrüstung nachhaltig zu
betreiben
die liste der enttäuschungen im
deutschen bestand ist lang sehr sehr
lang eines von unendlich vielen
beispielen dafür ist die fregatte baden
württemberg es handelt sich um den neue
fregatten klasse f125 als nachfolger der
f1 22 gedacht die bundesregierung gab es
2007 insgesamt vier einheiten davon in
auftrag und erst nach jahrelangen
verzögerungen und enormen
kostenüberschreitungen wurden diese an
die marine ausgeliefert aufgrund sich
ständig ändernde anforderungen der
bundeswehr zum beispiel in bezug auf
mehr raum zur unterbringung der
bordhubschrauber verschob sich die
auslieferung von 2009 in die jahre 2016
bis 2018 es kam zu erheblichen
überschreitungen der tonnage und vielen
einschränkungen gegenüber dem
ursprünglichen plan die es den fregatten
unmöglich gemacht hätte im ernstfall die
aufgabe zu erfüllen für die sie
entworfen worden waren sie mussten sogar
nach der auslieferung zur nachbesserung
an den hersteller zurückgeschickt werden
ein vorgang der in der geschichte
deutschland zuvor noch nie vorgekommen
war
die deutsche marine hat beschlossen ihre
aufgeblähte neue fregatte zu weihnachten
an den hersteller zurückzuschicken und
falls ihr euch im folgenden an die
endlose geschichte des pleite flughafens
berlin-brandenburg erinnert fühlt dürft
ihr euch schon zurecht die frage stellen
haben wir es hier schon mit einer
systemischen krankheit zu tun bevor wir
uns jedoch der makro analyse zu wenden
lasst uns kurz unter die lupe nehmen was
eigentlich bei diesem track garten im
detail schief lief
nun schon vor fertigstellung muss der
2015 der lack unterhalb der wasserlinie
erneuert werden geistigen verwendung
einer falschen farbe zu muschel gerufen
ablation gekommen war vorher hatte es
schon monatelange verzögerungen wegen
der brandschutz beschichtung und er
kabel gegeben brandschutz ick hör dir
trapsen dann gab es probleme mit dem
getriebe des haupt betriebs im januar
2017 war der bau der vier schiffe schon
29 monate im rückstand davon 15 monate
für überarbeitung der konstruktion acht
monate wegen mangelhaften brandschutz
anstrichs nun sechs monate wegen
verzögerungen bei der verlegung der b
500 kilometer kabel geschäft die
indienststellung der baden württemberg
wahl für 2017 vorgesehen aufgrund
schwerwiegender mängel wurde sie jedoch
ende 2017 an die hersteller
zurückgegeben massive probleme gab es
vor allem bei der software aber auch bei
schiffsfonds unter übrigen ausrüstung
wie dem radar dem wasser
aufbereitungssystem unter lebensmittel
kühl thyssenkrupp marine systems gelobte
die mängel zu beseitigen und nannte
daraufhin zunächst das jahr 2018 als
neues ziel für die indienststellung
tatsächlich sollte es dann aber doch
noch ein jahr länger dauern die die
stellung der fregatte baden württemberg
erfolgt am 17 juni 2009 10 immerhin bei
der lieferung der übrigen drei fregatten
der f125 klasse kam ist nicht mehr zu
derart krassen verzögerungen die in
nordrhein westfalen lief mit nur noch
zweijähriger verspätung im juni 2020 vom
stapel die sachsen anhalt wurde im
zweiten quartal 2021 und die kein land
pfalz im ersten quartal 2022 bündnis
gestellt hat gut aber lasst uns im
rahmen einer qualifizierten diagnose
eine ebene höher
als der ingenieur hatte ich schon oft
genug mit großprojekten zu tun in denen
sich anforderungen laufend ändern gar
ändern müssen in denen der fokus dann
nur noch am rumfliegen ist kosten
explodieren und liefertermine am
laufenden band zur makulatur werden der
grund dafür ist meist eine mangelhafte
kultur der planung kommunikation
qualitätssicherung des risiko- und
komplexitätsmanagement muss war sowohl
auf seiten des auftragnehmers als auch
auf der des auftraggebers diese
mangelhafte kultur entsteht meist über
einen längeren zeitraum und fußt auf
verschiedenen noch weitaus tiefer
liegenden ursachen hierzu zählen
korruption menschlicher faktoren
motivationstief hätte eine unbotmäßige
politisierung von
entscheidungsstrukturen und eben immer
wieder ein starrer aber wunder
bürokratischer wasserkopf keine
funktionierende agile und adäquate
planung eine effektive dynamische
planungs anpassung unmöglich macht weil
dies führt dann zu einer symptomatik wie
wir sie bei der bahn wird und beobachten
konnten aber wir haben es hier mit einem
historisch gesehen durchaus nicht ganz
so seltenen phänomen zu tun denn der
koloss selbst ganze einst blühender
zivilisation aufgrund einer in
kannibalische zustände ausgebuchten
staatsbürokratie ist keine seltenheit in
der tat handelt es sich um eine so
wichtiges und gewaltiges thema das wird
hierzu ein ganz eigenes video brauchen
werden vergesst also bitte nicht das abo
plus unbedingt das glöckchen falls euch
diese weit über das militärische
hinausgehende problematik und auch ihre
lösung interessiert aber keine angst ich
werde euch heute nicht endlos auf die
folter spannen und wenigstens ein paar
wichtige eckpunkte skizzieren die
geschichte der großen kulturen und
reiche lehrt uns dass diese vor allem
mit hilfe einer gut geölten program for
steigen und dann ebenso durch ihre quasi
wieder in den untergang getrieben haben
dieses immer gleiche muster haben
archäologen und
geschichtswissenschaftler von den
pharaonen bis in die neuzeit immer
wieder herausgearbeitet und es geht
folgendermaßen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erstens ein kollektiv das heißt
volksstamm oder staat schafft ist eine
sehr effiziente und effektive stars
verwaltung aufzubauen dadurch gewinnt
dieses kollektiv einen erheblichen
wettbewerbsvorteil gegenüber
benachbarten staaten stemmen den völkern
usw zweitens mit hilfe des enormen
organisatorischen vorteils gelingt ist
die anderen staaten zu dominieren so
waren oder fühlt sich abhängig zu machen
dies kann auch wirtschaftliche
militärische kulturelle administrative
oder diplomatischer weise geschehen oder
einer kombination dieser faktoren
drittens es manchmal jahrzehnte oder gar
jahrhunderte lang erfolgs wird die so
erfolgreiche bürokratie immer weiter
ausgebaut nach dem motto mehr hilft mehr
bzw
dieser staatsapparat hat uns sehr viel
gutes gebracht also wird es uns durch
noch mehr staatsapparat noch besser
gehen klingt ja erstmal einleuchtend man
bleibt einfach beide gewinner strategie
man fährt einfach immer weiter auf der
siegerstraße und gibt aber immer mehr
gas doch dann kommt tippens und
unbemerkt der wendepunkt ab einem
bestimmten bürokratisierung straat
kehren die bürokraten mehr oder weniger
unterbewusst und automatisch den spieß
einfach um ich muss sie dienen der
erhaltung und erweiterung des
wohlergehens von bevölkerung nation sein
diese dienen immer mehr nur noch der
erhaltung und erweiterung des
staatswesens an sich der staatsapparat
die politik und die bürokratie werden zu
parasitären selbstzweck die nation
begleitet in ihre kannibalistische phase
wohlgemerkt dies ist ein vollkommen
natürlicher vorgang der mit dem kippen
des macht gleichgewichts zu gunsten der
bürokraten losgetreten wird fünfter die
bürokratie verbraucht dann ab einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt mehr ressourcen als
sie dem staatswesen einbringt das heißt
mit mehr bürokratie kit ist im menschen
immer schlechter als mit weniger
wohlgemerkt dies war vor punkt 5 an das
programm kann also ein segen sein oder
ein fluch ist kommt immer auf die dosis
an und den kontext sechster da die
politiker und bürokraten über immer mehr
finanzieller brisach torische und
personelle ressourcen verfügen und zwar
dann näher als sie zur erfüllung ihrer
ursprünglichen aufgabe und brauche sich
gleichzeitig jedoch vor dem verlust
dieser im grunde ungerechtfertigt mit
überschuss ressourcen und der damit
verbundenen persönlichen macht fürchten
beiden sie ihre befugnisse immer mehr in
alle bereiche für staat und gesellschaft
aus und zwar eben mit hilfe jener
überschuss ressourcen sitzens ab einem
bestimmten punkt erreicht diese
eigentlich aus dir natürlichen
verlustängsten und kontrollsucht
hervorgegangenen macht absoluten
charakter auch wenn die mittel und
strukturen zu ihrer aufrechterhaltung
legitimation und durchsetzung schön
verpackt in wohlklingenden namen und
altruistisch ist erzielt daher kommen
deren erreichbarkeit übrigens meist
unmöglich oder nicht nachweisbar ist ab
diesem punkt ist keine ordnete umkehr
ohne einschneidende und
gesamtgesellschaftlich sehr kostspielige
dramatische umwälzungen mehr möglich
denn der point of no return wurde
bereits bei punkt 4 überschritten und no
return bedeutet diesem fall wirklich ist
kein zurück mehr zu punkt 3 man muss
wieder bei null anfangen im besten fall
[Musik]
aber noch sind wir weit vom kollaps
entfernt erachtens kann dieses nun durch
funktionale staatswesen mitsamt seiner
volkswirtschaft noch eine weile vor sich
dahin existieren oder sogar noch
kurzzeitige phasen des erfolgs erleben
schließlich sind zu diesem zeitpunkt
noch immer einige sehr leistungsfähige
elemente vorhanden die unter den alten
nun nicht mehr vorhanden bedingungen
entstanden sind viele kluge köpfe noch
immer mehr oder weniger leistungsfähige
unternehmen pflichtbewusste beamte gut
trainierte und motivierte soldaten und
sogar einige kompetente politiker auch
wenn all diese leistungsträger nun wie
aus der zeit gefallen erscheinen durch
die meinungs- eliten marginalisiert
werden und der lebensraum durch den
permanent überproportional an opulenz
bürokratie immer weiter eingeschränkt
wird aber meistens kommt es dann doch
irgendwann unweigerlich dazu dass eine
solcher staat ganz einfach von einem
anderen erfolgreichen start oder einer
vitalen kultur überrannt und eingenommen
wird in den geschichtsbüchern ist dann
meist nur dieses einschneidende ereignis
vermerk zum beispiel ein krieg eine
letzte belagerung eine entscheidende
schlacht doch der krieg die belagerung
und die niederlage waren nur als symptom
ihre ursache liegt irgendwo zwischen
punkt 3 und 4 doch über diese
langweiligen ereignislosen details steht
nichts in den geschichtsbüchern meistens
sind sie ja erst 2schneidig uneindeutig
die weitere kleine erhöhung der
abgabenlast nur um ein paar gut gemeinte
dinge mehr zu finanzieren nur noch eine
weitere subvention um eine gebeutelte
branche zu retten oder die irrationalen
bürger zu gutem verhalten zu erziehen
nur noch ein paar strengere
brandschutzvorschriften oder
hygienemaßnahmen wer würde schließlich
nicht so viele leben retten wollen wie
nur geht antidiskriminierungs
beauftragte und gesetze auch für die
allerkleinsten benachteiligte gruppe in
unserer gesellschaft denn wer will schon
als ungerecht ist und asoziales noch
geld mit ein paar milliarden für neue
aktiv systeme in allen behörden und
gesundheitseinrichtungen mit endlich
gender gerechten formularen und
anschreiben wer will schon in einem
staat leben dessen verwaltung nicht
respektiert als was sich die eigenen
bürger identifizieren und last but not
least
da wäre gegen anspruchsvollere
beschaffungs vergabe und redford in
richtlinien und zwar überall bis zum
anschlag gibt der korruption keine
chance na ja wie gesagt all das sind
schöne dinge aber sie stellen viele
kleine marginale manchmal aber auch
größere komplexität zuwächse bei
gesetzen und verwaltungsprozessen da
inklusive der schaffung ein paar neuer
zuständigkeiten stellen abteilungen
behörden oder gleich ministerien es gibt
ja schließlich sachzwänge und ein
bisschen luft nach oben ist ja immer
vorhanden nur dass diese luft denjenigen
genommen wird welche eigentlich wachsen
sollen um die leistung zu erbringen
[Musik]
und dieser leistungsträger ist im falle
der bundeswehr eben die kämpfende truppe
diese muss trotz eines 50 milliarden
haushalt aufgrund einer ins kafkaeske
entarteten verwaltungs und wirtschafts
bürokratie manchmal so sehr
improvisieren das ist wirklich peinlich
dort ein panzergrenadierbataillon nahm
2015 an einer nato übung in norwegen
teil dort fehlten die geschütze auf den
gepanzerten fahrzeugen des typs boxer
seht her was die soldaten daraufhin
hatten die
bundeswehrsoldaten montierten kurzerhand
besenstiele auf ihre gepanzerten
fahrzeuge weil kanonenrohre fehlten
alles geschehen bei einer nato übung
verrückt aber wenn es nur bei den diesen
spielen geblieben wäre angeblich musste
sich die betroffene einheit für die
teilnahme an der übung des haltet euch
fest mehr als 14.300
ausrüstungsgegenstände bei 56
verschiedenen einheiten der bundeswehr
borgen das heißt auf eigene faust
zusammen glauben braucht ihr noch mehr
beispiele für den dysfunktionalen
zustand der deutschen ausrüstungs
bürokratie kein problem
nur 951 tiger kampfhubschrauber und
weniger als 30 prozent der euro und
tornado kampfjets deutschlands kunden
ende 2018 fliegen der grund dafür der
mangel an ersatzteilen war so groß dass
man funktionsfähige einheiten kurzerhand
als reserven zum ausschlachten musste
klar dass dann insgesamt weniger gerät
einsatzbereit ist und klar ist auch dass
piloten deshalb weniger möglichkeiten
zum fliegen hatten und den piloten von
denen immer alle als kind schon fliegen
wollten eben nicht fliegen können sorgt
das vergewaltigen frost seither
kündigungswelle warum unsere
kampfpiloten völlig gefrustet sind
genervt von mangel- und bürokratie
wandern soldaten in die freie wirtschaft
ab und natürlich sind es wohl nicht die
mit der schlechtesten qualifikation die
zuerst gehen negativ auslese par
excellence ist ja wieder so eine
gemeinsamkeit die die bundeswehr mit der
russischen armee teilt siehe unser video
dazu dass ich euch verlinkt werden das
alles gilt auch für die anderen
teilstreitkräfte mangel wo and man
schaut
[Musik]
und den leopard 2 panzer an einen der
besten panzer der welt sind zeitweise
nur die hälfte einsatzbereit ebenso noch
150 der 350 puma panzer von den 15 a400m
transportflugzeugen waren 2018 nur drei
flugtauglich 2017 konnte über mehrere
monate kein einziges der sechs deutschen
u boote in see stechen im mai 2022 sind
es immerhin zwei nebenbei bemerkt einige
zuschauer haben uns die frage gestellt
ob die nur spärlichen lieferungen die
leeren versprechen der bundesregierung
bezüglich der waffenhilfe an die ukraine
absicht darstellen oder ob einfach
nichts da ist nun dazu kann man nur
sagen beides trifft zu was dem unwillen
angeht der ist reichlich vorhanden zum
beispiel was die blockade des
kanzleramts bei ausfuhrgenehmigungen an
lieferwege und liefert belege deutsche
rüstungsfirmen angeht aber dies ist ein
thema für ein separates video
insbesondere die sich dahinter
verbergenden motive der unwille ist also
ganz sicher die eine komponente des
deutschen versagens bei der ukraine
hilfe die andere komponente ist aber die
tatsache dass man tatsächlich über kaum
funktionsfähig
kurzfristig haben wir nichts zur
verfügung was er wirklich schnell und
zeitnah liefern können annalena baerbock
deutsche außenministerin außenministerin
berbalk hat im gegensatz zu kanzler
scholz keine motive hier etwas zu
verschleiern oder zu vertuschen ganz
abgesehen von der kurz und
mittelfristigen unfähigkeit der ukraine
bei der verteidigung zu helfen hat die
mangelsituation jedoch noch eine ganz
andere langfristige konsequenz denn wie
ihr wisst braucht eine schlagkräftige
armee auf gut ausgebildetes und
motiviertes personal doch wie kann man
soldaten gut ausbilden wenn das material
steht an den ausgebildet werden soll man
kann nicht alles durch besenstiele
ersetzen und wie attraktiv ist wohl ein
arbeitgeber der solche schlagzeilen
produziert die wir sie eben gesehen
haben kein wunder also dass kaum junge
und qualifizierte menschen die mich am
leben etwas besseres anfangen können
ihren weg zur bundeswehr kennt die
bundeswehr hat probleme dringend
benötigte rekruten anzuwerben die zahl
der neuen soldaten sank im vergangenen
jahr auf ein rekordtief von 20.000 ihr
seht also die striche ignoranz der
deutschen politik gegenüber der
verteidigungsfähigkeit ihrer armee und
ihrem missbrauch für zweckfremde
ideologische partikularinteressen
tiefgreifend langfristige schäden in so
vielen bereichen hinterlassen dass eine
schnelle und einfache korrektur
ausgeschlossen werden kann doch nun die
frage die sich viele von euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich stellen gibt es für
dieses ganze schlammmassen überhaupt
eine lösung erreichen die 100 milliarden
euro aus dem sondervermögen aus um eine
sog das militär wieder aufzubauen wofür
und wie sollte deutschland das ganze
geld ausgeben nun erste ideen gibt es
aufgepasst
[Musik]
lektion gelernt abwarten
nach an dem was ich euch gerade erzählt
habe dürfte klar sein die deutschen
streitkräfte sind veraltet und zwar
nicht nur veraltet sondern in vielen
fällen in einem fast maroden zustand und
das obwohl jedes jahr mehr als 50
milliarden euro aus den taschen der
deutsche steuerzahler über den
verteidigungshaushalt ja wohin
eigentlich fließen nun die traurige
wahrheit ist dass ein großer teil davon
vollkommen kontraproduktiv assoziiert
ist die bundeswehr steckt also irgendwo
zwischen 6 und 7 jenes historischen
musters fest dass ich euch vorhin
dargelegt habe leider kann ich von hier
aus nicht genau ermitteln wie viel der
mittel des der etats dazu dienen leuten
pöstchen zu sichern und strukturen
aufrechtzuerhalten die ganz und gar
nicht teil der lösung sind sondern im
gegenteil teil des problems ich kann
euch jedoch sagen dass dies
logischerweise ein beträchtlicher teil
sein muss denn 50 milliarden für solche
selige ergebnisse zu verpulvern spricht
für sich so ohne diese kontraproduktiven
strukturen diesmal zusätzliche 100
milliarden euro aus einem sondervermögen
aber wir wollen nicht unfair sein
schauen wir uns erst mal ganz nüchtern
einige beispiele aus der derzeitigen
einkaufsliste an hoch
als ersatz für den alten tornado-jets
will die bundeswehr 35 amerikanische
kampfflugzeuge vom typ f 35 kaufen die
f35 gilt als der modernste fighter
bombay der welt er dient künftig der
luftabwehr aber auch der sogenannten
nuklearen teilhabe das heißt ein teil
der fw32 ist dafür vorgesehen in
deutschland gelagert amerikanische
atomwaffen ins ziel zu bringen falls das
jemals erforderlich sein sollte über die
f35 haben ein eigenes video gedreht das
trinken werde deswegen kann ich mich
hier nicht wiederholen außerdem werden
15 modelle des eurofighters für die
elektronische kampfführung
weiterentwickelt und angeschafft darüber
hinaus gibt es drohen und hubschrauber
[Musik]
für die marine wird es weitere korrekten
vom typ 130 fregatten des typs 126
gebote geben beim heer soll der
schützenpanzer puma nachgerüstet werden
und man will einen nachfolger für den
leopard 2 entwickeln dem soldaten werde
künftig neue nachtsichtgeräte neue
stiefel und kann frank schule zugute
kommen und für die digitalisierung
sichere kommunikation und cyber
sicherheit stehen künftig mit 21
milliarden euro zur verfügung hier die
aufteilung des geldregens auf die
verschiedenen teilstreitkräfte ok klingt
ja erst mal nicht schlecht aber erreicht
das eigentlich wäre diese ganze ausgaben
orgie leiten nun an dieser stelle
stoßende auf das zweitgrößte problem der
bundeswehr nach seiner politischen
führung und dieses sitzt in koblenz
[Musik]
dort residiert das uns zur ausrüstung
informationstechnik und nutzung der
bundeswehr abgekürzt bnd dabei wenn er
sich an viel treffender das akronym für
diese behörde im amerikanischen militärs
ag kuba fucked up beyond all rita
unrettbar kaputt ohne reparierbar das
amt geht leider als ein wahres
bürokratiemonster mit einem gewirr von
stabsstellen und unterabteilungen und
tausenden von mitarbeitern es ist aber
zugleich der eigentliche ein käufer für
die bundeswehr egal ob es dabei um
klopapier oder kampfpanzer geht doch
diese einkaufsprozesse dauern lange ganz
lange unerträglich lange kritikern gilt
die koblenzer behörde als der
wesentliche bremse bei der beschaffung
von ausrüstung für die truppe und damit
als ausgangspunkt für alle daraus
resultierenden probleme bürokratie ist
leider auch ein meister aus deutschland
und bürokratie blüht und gedeiht wenn
man geld wie aus gießkannen regnen lässt
und ist nicht klug investiert nun ja
immerhin soll ein neues gesetz
verschaffen mit dem bundeswehr
beschaffungs beschleunigungsgesetz
anfang juli im parlament verabschiedet
soll jetzt alles angeblich schneller
gehen aber ob das alles ausreicht 0 ist
nun mal fußball der point of no return
und no return bedeutet nur dass all
dieses sauteuer herumdoktern an einem
toten gaul stattfindet
[Musik]
die einzig richtige konsequenz daraus
wäre ein ende mit schrecken einen
neuanfang tabula rasa denn bevor man
wirklich denkt muss erst mal radikal das
unkraut gejätet werden sonst wird all
der dinge nur vom unkraut aufgenommen so
dass es die nutzpflanzen schließlich
noch stärker überwacht und ein derart
von hartnäckigem unkraut aller art in
beschlag genommen das feld muss kräftig
umgepflügt werden aber dazu müsste man
zu vielen mit warmen pöstchen versorgten
auf die füße treten und zu viele gute
beziehungen und seilschaften stören aber
es das neue wohnung ist der beschaffungs
und gesetzt der flug der benötigt wird
oder doch eher nur eine kleine spielzeug
schaufeln experten sind hier äußerst
skeptisch denn bei näherer betrachtung
handelt es sich wieder einmal um eine
schöne wohlklingende verpackung welche
hauptsächlich dazu dient eine menge
zwecks trennte partikularinteressen in
die gesetzesbücher zu hieven leider sind
die anzeichen dafür mehr als deutlich
denn viele elemente des gesetzes wären
schon heute auf der grundlage der
bestehenden regelungen möglich auf der
einen seite sind da durchaus vernünftige
dinge enthalten so soll zukünftig auch
die gemeinsame beschaffung mit anderen
staaten der europäischen union eine noch
größere rolle spielen andererseits will
man die vergabe ausgerechnet durch einen
sehr gefährlichen trick beschleunigen
weniger wettbewerb und ihr könnt euch
schon denken dass dieses stichwort bei
visual politik alle alarmglocken läuten
lässt ich meine wir hätten gesagt dass
er mehr wettbewerb zu mehr
wirtschaftlichkeit und schließlich
besseren qualitativen angeboten führt
auch was die liefertermine angeht wir
hätten gesagt dass durch den im gesetz
festgelegten faktischen wegfall des
gebots der los weißen farbe die
abhängigkeit von großen monopol
anbietern steigt und dass die
entsprechende vorhaben in der
vergangenheit zeigt und dies in der
nutzungsphase oftmals zu engpässen führt
denn bei verschiedenen waffensystemen
liegt die knappheit nicht darin
begründet dass zu wenig systeme
beschafft worden vielmehr sind
insbesondere die abhängigkeiten so dass
der öffentliche auftraggeber keinen
druck auf die monopolanbieter entfalten
kann weil er schlichtweg keine
alternative hat aber was wissen wir
schon über wirtschaft rüstung und so die
experten sitzen ja alle schon im
verteidigungsministerium in kuba amt und
natürlich auch im bundestag
[Musik]
denn wie die von den fraktionen von spd
bündnis 90 die grünen und der fdp
bereits im rahmen des gesetzesentwurfes
erfahren durften erfüllt das bunt ist
der beschaffungs beschleunigungsgesetz
auch einen ganz wichtigen bisher
sträflich vernachlässigten zweck nein es
geht diesmal nicht um schwangeren
gerechte schützenpanzer über die wir
schon in einem früheren video gewitzelt
haben diesmal haben es die deutschen
politiker doch tatsächlich geschafft
einen anderen bild aus den gleichen
video in der realität materialisieren zu
lassen wenn man höre und staune es ist
der klimawandel der ganz dringend die
einbeziehung von umweltbelangen in die
beschaffung von verteidigungs und
erfordert nicht zulässt des co2
ausstoßes wegen und insbesondere
besonders materialintensiven gütern ziel
ist es dabei das grüne leitmärkte auch
für eine nachhaltige
verteidigungsindustrie entstehen na also
da haben wir es was könnt ihr die
beschaffungs geschwindigkeit der
bundeswehr noch näher an die
lichtgeschwindigkeit heranbringen als
die grünen leitmärkte der größte
albtraum wladimir putins ja ja aber wenn
es der zwei mogelpackungen
sondervermögen und bundeswehr
beschaffungs beschleunigungsgesetz ist
übrigens auch nicht der internationalen
presse end gab
erster juli 2022 deutschland wird
vorgeworfen heimlich bei der
verteidigung zu sparen der deutsche
verteidigungshaushalt wird schrumpfen
weil die auswirkungen eines sonderfonds
in höhe von 100 milliarden euro
herausgerechnet werden heißt es in
offiziellen dokumenten aus dem die bild
zeitung zitiert kritiker sagen dass der
einmalige vor die kürzungen bei den
laufenden ausgaben verschleiert der asse
und heißt irreversiblen macht und
vertrauensverlust in deutschland bei
seinen nachbarn und verbündeten erlitten
hat durch das traurige agieren dieser
bundesregierung sagt kriegsausbruch wie
natürlich auch durch den fatalen
weichenstellung und fehleinschätzungen
ihrer vorgänger ist jedoch ein thema
sein eigenes video an dieser stelle
möchten wir noch eine weitere aktuelle
fehleinschätzung erwähnen und diese ist
das maß an dummheit welches die
regierung scholz uns allen unterstellt
man kann förmlich riechen welche mobile
von welcher der koalitionsparteien in
diese vorhaben hinein geschummelt wurde
um ihre jeweilige spezielle klientel zu
bedienen hauptsache dass sich alle einig
geworden sind die prognose für die
bundeswehr lautet daher weiterhin der
schrecken ohne ende geht weiter daher
werden wir auf jeden fall an diesem
thema dran bleiben und wir werden genau
hinsehen ob aus budgetplänen
wunschzettel und warmen worten auch
taten wären wie immer schonungslos und
ohne ideologische samt von schul und
jetzt seid ihr dran hättet ihr gedacht
dass die deutschen streitkräfte
tatsächlich in solch einem jämmerlichen
zustand sind und glaubt ihr die lösung
besteht im ausgeben von noch mehr geld
reicht das geld überhaupt wie immer sind
auf eure beiträge und diskussionen zum
diesem thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat was ja geht uns mit einem
leitpfosten und freunde und vergesst
nicht das abo mit blockieren keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich wollen uns auch jederzeit über
eine spende von euch mit der uns hilft
dieses projekt weiterzuführen in panik
dass und findet in der beschreibung
unter dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]